The fact that people aren't on their
knees in gratitude all the time for the
fact that we have central
heating and air conditioning and,
and pure water and reliable food.
It's just,
it is.
It's absolutely unbelievable.
And then the water supply was contaminated
with cholera for heaven's sakes.
Right?
People don't understand.
Okay.
I've had clean water,
fresh milk,
fresh orange juice,
all of these things.
There's a mom and all of the time,
all the time that that
western culture is heading.
Okay.
Become,
because we are so dependent on this,
on this invisible infrastructure where
a heading for an absolute catastrophe,
when hardest figure out how
to paralyze the power grid,
the entire culture will be chaotic.
You'll have mobs in the street.
Okay.
And within three days.
When and so suddenly the food supply
is interrupted and there's no light.
There's no,
no way to communicate.
There'll be like a robbery.
I mean that that is the way western
culture is going to collapse.
Okay.
And it won't take much just just
because we are so
interconnected and now we are.
So it's so,
it's so dependent on communications
and computers to the eat it.
I've,
I used to predict for years there'll be
an asteroid hitting the earth and you
have enough another
the solar flares work.
So back in,
this happens about once every century.
So back about 1880 and I
don't remember the exact year,
there was a significant
enough solar flare,
so that produces an electromagnetic pulse,
like a hydrogen bomb because the sun
is a hydrogen bomb and electromagnetic
pulse will emerge from the sun and wave
across the earth and it produces huge
spikes in electrical,
electrical,
current along anything that's
electronic and he'll burn them out.
It led it lip telegraph operators on
fire in the 18 hundreds and one of those
things took out the Quebec power grid
in 1985 and knocked out the whole
northeast corridor.
And so you figure those things
are about one in a century event,
but those single,
I have my brother in law
who's a very smart guy.
He designed the chip and the iPhone.
We were talking about political issues
the last time I went and saw him in San
Francisco.
And his notion was that all that the
government should be doing right now is
stress testing our infrastructure the
same way they stress test the banks
because we're so full of these
single points of failure that,
and I think you're absolutely right.
Luckily we've been,
um,
what would you call,
invaded by stupid terrorists
instead of smart terrorists?
Because a smart terrorist could do an
unbelievable amount of damage in a very
short period of time.
So when it's just God's good graces
that that hasn't happened yet.
And so,
and then what will happen
is that if the men,
the men will reconstruct civilization
while the women cower in the houses.
And I have the men go out
and do all the dirty work.
That's what's going to happen again.
Only men will,
will bring civilization back again.
Yeah.